if I'm hard on you it's because the  world is heart you've seen that and I  just need you stay out of trouble okay  [Music]  your brother just got out of prison I  know I've been away for a long time but  I want to make sure that you know that  you're important to me  I want you to be careful about him  welcome home my man I know I owe you  guys some money I just want you can all  I'm not dodging you let him go the hell  is that thing  what the hell is that I found it  somebody's gotta be looking for this  thing  [Music]  that thing your brother hasn't we need  to constantly tend to good  [Music]  Filan he's here somewhere dangerous  people coming after us  I know I'm not a good guy but it's been  pretty incredible to be brothers for the  first time whatever it has gotten him  into  we kind of figured out eventually I hope  you're ready for that  can't believe this whole time  you haven't told me  get away from my brother  maybe keep that thing on the first mode  yeah  you